Oh my god guys look at this. Look at this place. What a pretty pretty place. It's gorgeous. It's nice here right? I mean it's seriously nice here. It's a seriously great spot. I mean like are you guys serious?
天哪，大家看这个。看这个地方。多美多美的地方啊。太棒了。这里真不错，对吧？我是说这里真的很好。这是一个非常棒的地方。我是说，你们是认真的吗？
Dude I want you to be serious with me right now. Be serious right now. Okay guess what? We are serious. Yeah. Oh I hear now. Guess what? We are serious. Yeah. Oh, I hear what you're saying. We are SeriousXM. Welcome, listener, to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
老兄，我希望你现在对我也严肃点。现在严肃点。好吧，你猜怎么着？我们很严肃。对。哦，我听见了。你猜怎么着？我们很严肃。对。哦，我明白你的意思了。我们是 SiriusXM。欢迎听众来到 Smartless。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
Smart. Less. J.B., are you, sorry, I know you're tired, but are you having like issues, like connection issues or something? Oh, I could be. You're a little glitched. Yeah, I might need a new computer. Yeah, all my ports and holes are rusty. You might want to get another take on that. If you...
Smart。Less。J.B.，你，抱歉，我知道你很累，但你是不是遇到了什么问题，比如连接问题之类的？哦，有可能。你有点卡顿。对，我可能需要一台新电脑。对，我所有的接口和洞都生锈了。你可能得换个说法了。如果你……
You know what I mean? Let's put it a different way. After I finish at the computer store, go to the doctor. Or bring your computer to the doctor. So I apologize if I sound like a broken computer today, America. You don't need to apologize ever for anything. We love you. Yes, love. A lot.
你知道我的意思吗？换个方式说。等我在电脑店弄完后，就去看医生。或者把你的电脑带去看医生。所以如果我今天听起来像台坏掉的电脑，美国的朋友们，我向你们道歉。你永远不需要为任何事情道歉。我们爱你。是的，爱。非常爱。
You're very loved. Thanks, but I'm glitched out today. Okay, so, and don't worry about it. So anyway, I had, I just woke up a little bit ago, I had the craziest dream, I'm not making this up. I had a dream that was on. Was I in it? No.
你深受喜爱。谢谢，但我今天卡壳了。好吧，所以，别担心。总之，我，我刚醒来没多久，我做了一个超级疯狂的梦，我不是在瞎编。我做了一个梦，梦里有……我在里面吗？没有。
I don't wanna hear it. Okay, great. Yeah, you know, I actually, don't you love it? Isn't the narcissism and you just flare up when someone says, hey, I had a dream about you last night. I stop everything. I go, oh yeah? Shawn, was I in it?
我不想听。好吧，太棒了。对，你知道，其实，你不觉得吗？当别人说“嘿，我昨晚梦见你了”时，那种自恋和虚荣心不是会瞬间膨胀吗？我停下手里的一切。我说，哦，真的吗？肖恩，我在里面吗？
No, neither of you were in it. I was on the operating table and they took my heart out and I saw them taking all of it out. And the guy's like. Was it filled with jujubes? No, no. And the guy said, I said, okay, so some procedures, and I'm like, don't I need my heart to live all the blood?
没有，你们俩都不在里面。我躺在手术台上，他们把我的心脏掏了出来，我眼睁睁看着他们把整颗心都掏出来了。然后那家伙说……里面装满了枣椰果吗？没有，没有。然后那家伙说，我说，好吧，那有些程序，我说，我不需要心脏来维持全身的血液循环吗？
I can't live too long with it outside of my body, right? He's like, no, you'll be fine. And then he started giving me fried chicken. Swear to God. He started putting a breast of fried chicken in your chest? No, but making me eat it with it. He's like, you want some of my lunch? I was like, okay, I was fried chicken.
心脏离开我的身体，我活不了太久吧？他说，没事，你会没事的。然后他开始给我炸鸡。上帝发誓。他开始往你胸口塞一块炸鸡？没有，但让我一边开着胸一边吃。他说，你想吃我的午餐吗？我说，好吧，我要吃炸鸡。
Isn't that weird? What'd you have for dinner? I don't remember. What did I have for dinner? Really? Oh, I had pita bread with chicken and hummus. It's called a falafel? Yeah, that's it. Brrrr.
不觉得很诡异吗？你晚餐吃了什么？我不记得了。我晚餐吃了什么？真的吗？哦，我吃的是鸡肉鹰嘴豆泥皮塔饼。那叫法拉费吗？对，就是那个。呼噜。
Pft. Boy, this is bad today. Yeah, it is. Should we just get through our guys? Let's start over. Let's start over. Everyone back to one. Okay.
噗。天哪，今天这状态太差了。对啊，确实。我们要不要直接跟哥几个过一遍？重新开始吧。重新开始。大家各就各位。好吧。
Will, you forgot a couple of buttons at the top of your shirt real quick before we continue. It's real steamy out here right now. Is it? You look like George Hamilton. It's weird. Period. Period.
威尔，在我们继续之前，把衬衫最上面的一两颗扣子系上。外面现在闷热得像蒸桑拿。是吗？你看起来像乔治·汉密尔顿。这挺奇怪的。句号。句号。
I get period George Hamilton? Yeah. Like from what era? All right, great. Ready, here we go. Everybody's real tired today. I know, wait, wait, Sean, wait, JB, wait. I just woke up.
我看起来像乔治·汉密尔顿？对。哪个年代的？好吧，太棒了。准备好了，我们开始。大家今天都很累。我知道，等等，等等，肖恩，等等，JB，等等。我刚醒。
Did you? I really did, just like, did you have a dream? All right. Ha ha ha ha. Did you, Seanny, did you wake up usual, like wake up at four, awake till seven? I woke up, yeah, I woke up at four, started playing games and reading stuff,
是吗？我真的是，就像……你做梦了吗？好吧。哈哈哈哈。肖恩尼，你是不是像往常一样醒来，比如四点醒，然后醒到七点？我醒了，对，我四点醒的，开始玩游戏看东西，
and then I went back to bed pretty quickly. What was the game? Don't say games with an S on it, it's Candy Crush, period, isn't it? No, no, I usually play like Hearts, or I'll play Solitaire, or I'll play something mindless so it kind of gets me sleepy again. Oh, because Candy Crush is the real brain teaser.
然后很快又回去睡觉了。玩的是什么游戏？别说带复数的“游戏”，是糖果传奇（Candy Crush），对吧？不，不，我通常玩红心大战（Hearts），或者玩纸牌（Solitaire），或者玩点不费脑子的，这样能让我重新犯困。哦，因为糖果传奇可是真正的脑力大考验。
Yeah. You don't want to start the critical functioning at 4.30. A real brain teaser. I gotta get the yellows to match the bright reds. This is gonna keep you up. Exactly. All right, here we go. You guys, nobody's in the mood for us today,
对。你可不想在四点半就开启大脑的高级认知功能。真正的脑力大考验。我得把黄色的跟亮红色凑在一起。这绝对能让你毫无睡意。完全正确。好吧，我们开始。你们今天谁都不在状态，
but we're in the mood for our guests, so excited. Let's talk, he's too cool for school, guys. These are all your hints. I'd give anything for just a fraction of this man's brilliant acting and improv skills. Is he a mathematician? No, his first and last names start with the same letter. He's tall AF.
但我们对我们的嘉宾状态拉满，超级兴奋。我们来聊聊，他简直酷毙了，各位。这些都是给你们的提示。我愿意付出一切来换取这位男士那一丁点出色的演技和即兴表演技巧。他是数学家吗？不，他的名字和姓氏首字母相同。他身高逆天。
Soupy sales. That's what the kid's saying, no. He played Daddy Warbucks in Annie when he was 12. Like myself, a born and raised Midwestern boy, and also like myself, afraid of the ocean, he may or may not have juicy dirt on Jon Favreau. It's my new best friend, the always hilarious Vince Vaughn. Cut the shit.
苏皮·萨尔斯（Soupy Sales）。那小孩这么说的，不是。他12岁时在《安妮》里扮演了沃巴克斯爸爸。和我一样，是个土生土长的中西部男孩；也和我一样，恐海。关于乔恩·费儒（Jon Favreau），他手里可能掌握着猛料，也可能没有。我的新最佳好友，永远搞笑的文斯·旺（Vince Vaughn）。别扯淡了。
Cut the shit. What's happening? Oh, cut. How are you guys? Cut the shit. What's happening? Cut the shit. How are you guys? Cut the shit. Good to see you guys. Cut the motherfucking shit. Now I'm up.
别扯淡了。怎么回事？哦，切。你们好吗？别扯淡了。怎么回事？别扯淡了。你们好吗？别扯淡了。很高兴见到你们。别他妈扯淡了。我现在来劲了。
Now I'm up. Now I'm up too. Vince. Good morning. I like the steamy. The steamy's excellent. It's confident in the morning, Will, and I like that.
我现在来劲了。我现在也来劲了。文斯。早上好。我喜欢这股闷热劲。这股闷热劲太棒了。早晨就这么自信，威尔，我喜欢这样。
And the necklace, that draws my eyes as well. Dreams are important. I don't know what fried chicken in a dream means, but I like that. And a necklace that draws my eyes as well. Dreams are important. I don't know what fried chicken in a dream means, but I think it's something that you might want to look under the hood. And Bateman, I love that you are still figuring out how to record, because I'm the same way. I can't turn on a streamer without my 13-year-old daughter
还有那条项链，也吸引了我的目光。梦想很重要。我不知道梦里出现炸鸡意味着什么，但我喜欢这样。还有那条吸引我目光的项链。梦想很重要。我不知道梦里出现炸鸡意味着什么，但我认为这说明你或许该检查一下引擎盖下面了。还有贝特曼，我很高兴你还在琢磨怎么录音，因为我也是这样。我女儿不帮我，我都打不开流媒体。
helping me. Well, hold on. I feel this is like an old family member that I haven't seen for how many years, Vince? It feels like 10 years. It's been a while. It's great to see you. You too, pal. How's Kyla?
好吧，等等。我觉得这就好像一个我不知道多少年没见的老家庭成员，文斯？感觉像10年。好久不见了。很高兴见到你。我也是，老兄。凯拉（Kyla）好吗？
Kyla's doing great. Yeah, she's doing great. Kyla's your wife for my sister Tracy, who doesn't know that? Who is a registered broker? Yes, Tracy. Kyla's a woman that I've asked to... I took her hand. Canadian gal.
凯拉非常好。对，她非常好。凯拉是你老婆，还是我妹妹特雷シー（Tracy）的？谁不知道这个？谁是个注册经纪人？对，特雷シー。凯拉是我求婚的那个女人……我牵起了她的手。加拿大姑娘。
Canadian. Oh, yeah. I went north of the border on that, you know what it's about. Fucking A button. Oh yeah? What? Fucking A rights.
加拿大。哦，对。我在那上面跨过了国界，你知道这是怎么回事。他妈的A级按钮。哦，是吗？什么？他妈的A级权利。
Oh, fucking A rights. Fucking beauty, that's beauty. I was singing your praises the other day. Again, it's usually once a week when I talk about, there is no one better at what you do than you, my friend. I don't know if you listen, but we always talk about you on this. No, I listen a lot, and that's nice coming
哦，他妈的A级权利。太棒了，真是个尤物。我前几天还在对你大加赞赏。再说一次，通常是一周一次，当我谈到时，我会说，没有人能像你一样把你的工作做得比你更出色，我的朋友。我不知道你有没有听，但我们总是在节目里谈论你。不，我经常听，听到你们三个这么说，我很高兴。
from all three of you. All three of you are funny and joke around, and I've had fun with all of you. You have such a facility. You're so funny in such an easy way. From the first moment I ever saw you perform, which was swingers, you were just fucking, from that moment on I was like,
你们三个都很有趣，也很爱开玩笑，而且我和你们每个人都合作得很开心。你太有天赋了。你幽默得那么自然。从我看到你表演的第一刻起，也就是《求爱俗辣》（Swingers），你简直他妈的……从那一刻起我就觉得，
this guy is, he's a fucking grand slam, every day is the home run derby for Vince O'Han. I didn't think so, here's why. I was thought, by the way, is the picture locked? The picture is locked, but let's have your notes. Well I was just, I thought maybe you could try a little harder on me. Oh shit.
这家伙，他简直是个他妈的全垒打，文斯·奥汉（Vince O'Han）每天都在打全垒打大赛。我不这么认为，原因如下。我当时想，顺便问一句，画面锁定了吗？画面锁定了，但让我们听听你的意见。好吧，我只是觉得，你在我身上或许可以再努力一点。哦，见鬼。
But Vince, what, what was. I left a little on the field to be honest in that one. What was before swingers? How did you come loaded for Bear in that? I have all of those questions. Was it, I know a little of this, but my brain is not working as well as it used to. So remind me of what I used to know.
但文斯，什么，什么……老实说，我在那部戏里有所保留。拍《求爱俗辣》之前是什么情况？你是怎么带着充足的弹药去拍那部戏的？我有所有这些问题。是不是，我知道一点这方面的，但我的大脑已经没有过去那么好用了。所以提醒我一下我以前都知道些什么。
I know there's Chicago in there. Well, like you, I started acting very young, but just in community stuff. So like both my parents worked, so I was always performing, I just gravitated to it. You know, probably lack of success in other areas. And for some reason I felt like good attention there. And I have to say, like, as a kid,
我知道里面有芝加哥的成分。嗯，和你一样，我很早就开始演戏了，但只是在社区活动里。所以因为我父母都工作，我一直在表演，我只是自然而然地被它吸引了。你知道，可能是因为在其他方面缺乏成功吧。不知为什么，我在那里感受到了良好的关注。而且我必须说，作为一个孩子，
this is something I talked to Phillips about. That show that you did that was on, where you were such a smart ass on that show, what was that one called, was it Checkerboard? Yeah, it's your move. It's your move. You were so fucking funny in that. Me and Todd, when we were working with you
这是我和菲利普斯（Phillips）谈过的事。你演过的那部电视剧，你在里面那么爱耍小聪明，那部叫什么来着，是《下棋高手》（Checkerboard）吗？对，是《轮到你了》（It's Your Move）。你在里面太他妈搞笑了。我和托德（Todd）一起工作时
on Starsky and Hutch, I brought up, he's like, I loved him on that fucking show. You were such a fucking confident kid who didn't care what people thought about you. But I just kind of liked stuff always as a kid. That stuff made me laugh. Like Sanford and Son, he made me laugh. Absolutely.
在拍《警界双雄》（Starsky and Hutch）的时候，我提起过，他说：“我太喜欢他在那部破剧里的表现了。”你当时是个多么自信的孩子，根本不在乎别人怎么看你。但我从小就挺喜欢那种东西的。那些东西能让我笑。比如《桑福德和儿子》（Sanford and Son），那节目能让我笑。绝对的。
You know what I mean? Like Red Fox, he just didn't care and it wasn't like he had a lot of skills, but he wasn't gonna have his day bothered. I don't know, I just kind of found that stuff funny. So I was always performing, started doing improv in high school with Improv Olympic and got an agent in high school and started working and then came out.
你知道我的意思吗？比如红福克斯（Red Fox），他根本不在乎，而且并不是说他有很多技能，但他绝不会让任何人毁了自己的一天。我不知道，我就是觉得那些东西很好笑。所以我一直在表演，高中时开始在即兴奥运会（Improv Olympic）做即兴表演，高中时就签了经纪人开始工作，然后就出道了。
But where swingers we, we got benefited from, I think is John and I were hanging out, he came out to Los Angeles and then he sort of took stuff that was going on in our lives and jokes and things that we said and informed the screenplay. And because we were raising money for it, it's almost like Nichols used to do, where he would perform on Broadway before they would shoot something. We were trying to raise money,
但《求爱俗辣》这部电影让我们受益的地方在于，我认为是乔恩和我经常一起混，他来到洛杉矶，然后他把我们生活中的经历、笑话以及我们说过的话融入了剧本中。因为我们在为它筹集资金，这有点像迈尔斯（Nichols）以前做的那样，在他们拍摄某些东西之前先在百老汇表演。我们在试图筹集资金，
so we must have had five, six table readings of that thing. And so we had time to investigate it and think about it and tweak it slightly. And so when we went to go film it and the bars were open and they weren't closed, we weren't bothered because we were so well versed with the material. Oh, that's amazing. Speaking about though, you grew up in Chicago, so did I.
所以我们大概对那东西进行了五、六次剧本围读。因此我们有时间去深入研究它、思考它并做一些微调。所以当我们去拍摄的时候，酒吧都是开着的，没有关门，我们一点也不慌，因为我们对剧本已经非常熟悉了。哦，太棒了！说到这个，你在芝加哥长大，我也是。
Not far from you in the suburbs, the great suburbs. Yeah, you grew up in Buffalo Grove, I grew up in Glen Ellyn. Yeah, Buffalo Grove and then Lake Forest, and then I went to Lake Forest afterwards. Yeah, Lake Forest is beautiful, by the way. Yeah. But wait a minute, isn't that where we were born,
离你很近，在郊区，伟大的郊区。对，你在布法罗格罗夫（Buffalo Grove）长大，我在格伦埃林（Glen Ellyn）长大。对，布法罗格罗夫，然后是森林湖（Lake Forest），后来我去了森林湖。对，森林湖很漂亮，顺便说一句。对。但等一下，我们不是在那里出生的吗？
we're the same age. Same year. So weird. Wait, wait, both in Chicago. Holy, holy shit, Sean, you're right. You and 25 million other people, that's fucking crazy. What are the fucking odds? Hang on, they're pretty good.
我们同岁。同年。太诡异了。等等，等等，都在芝加哥。天哪，天哪，肖恩，你说得对。你和另外2500万人一样，这他妈太疯狂了。几率有多大？等等，几率挺高的。
What are the odds that two Americans were born in the third largest city in the country and now live in the second largest city in the country? But wait it gets better. Sean's got a follow-up. Everybody hold on. It gets better. So wait did you I read that you did Children's Theatre there? Did you do Children's Theatre? Yeah as a kid I was in I was in community theater where we would play the we would play the the adult roles as as young young. Where did where was that do you remember? That was at the Borton Community Center which is a place,
两个美国人出生在全国第三大城市，现在住在全国第二大城市，这种几率有多大？但还没完，更精彩的来了。肖恩还有后续。大家稍等。更精彩的来了。所以等等，我读到你在那里演过儿童戏剧？你演过儿童戏剧吗？对，我小时候演过，我在社区剧院演过，我们在那里扮演成年人的角色，以极其年轻的……那是在哪里演的，你还记得吗？那是在波顿社区中心（Borton Community Center），那个地方，
Robin Williams went to high school when it used to be a high school. Like Bugsy Malone, right? You guys were playing. Yes, without the pies, but exactly. Remember that one with Baio? They dazzled with the pies. It was all okay, because they threw pies.
罗宾·威廉姆斯（Robin Williams）上高中时就在那儿，当时那里还是个高中。就像《龙蛇小霸王》（Bugsy Malone）那样，对吧？你们当时在演……是的，没有派，但完全是那样。还记得巴约（Baio）演的那部吗？他们用派来闪瞎人眼。一切都好，因为他们扔派。
Remember that one? Arnett, you had to see that one. Yeah, they had a Tommy gun that shot cream puffs, right? Was that McNichol? I think it was Kristen McNichol. Was McNichol? I think it was Christy McNichol. Was McNichol charming in front of the camera with bail? I remember... They were throwing whipped cream at each other and dressed as gangsters.
还记得那部吗？阿内特（Arnett），你肯定看过那部。对，他们有一把发射奶油泡芙的汤姆逊冲枪，对吧？那是麦克尼科尔（McNichol）吗？我觉得是克里斯蒂·麦克尼科尔（Christy McNichol）。是麦克尼科尔吗？我觉得是克里斯蒂·麦克尼科尔。麦克尼科尔在镜头前和巴约在一起时很有魅力吗？我记得……他们打扮成黑帮分子，互相扔鲜奶油。
I was so in love with Christy McNichol when I was a kid. I remember specifically jogging with my dad one morning in the quiet streets of Woodland Hills, and I started crying. I trailed behind him and I just started crying because I had a dream about her and I couldn't believe that it wasn't real. And I just started weeping. It must have been 10 or 11 or 12. So in love with her.
我小时候疯狂迷恋克里斯蒂·麦克尼科尔。我特别记得有一天早上，我和我爸爸在伍德兰希尔斯（Woodland Hills）安静的街道上慢跑，我开始哭泣。我落在他后面，开始哭泣，因为我梦见了她，我简直不敢相信那不是真的。我开始放声大哭。我当时一定只有10岁、11岁或12岁。对她爱得深沉。
And now I'm going to make her out like her. No, never met her. Not once. I think I met her brother. There's so much about that story is psychotic. There's so much about that. Yeah. That is fucking. There's so much about that. That is, Yeah. Yeah.
而现在我要把她……像她一样。不，从来没见过她。一次也没有。我想我见过她哥哥。那个故事里有太多神经质的成分。有太多……对。太他妈……这里面有太多……那是，对。对。
Fucking. Red flag alert. I mean, fuck. Wait, but then you moved out, you moved out in 88, is that right? You moved out in 88. Yes, right after high school. I gave up on my academic career.
他妈的。红牌警告。我的天，操。等等，但后来你搬出去了，你在88年搬出去了，对吗？你在88年搬出去了。是的，高中刚毕业。我放弃了我的学术生涯。
No college. Oh, so no college. Good for you, me too. Good for you. I was the same way. It takes a lot of guts. It's easy to go to college. It takes a lot of guts to fucking pass it out. Even more bold is not even graduating high school.
没上大学。哦，所以没上大学。真棒，我也是。真棒。我也是这样。这需要很大的勇气。上大学很容易。要他妈的放弃它才需要极大的勇气。更大胆的是连高中都没毕业。
You're welcome. Yeah, you're right. Yeah, I only graduated because it was important to my parents, but I was done. I was ready to move on. Yeah, I get that. Wait, what was the goal? Hey, did you go to school for four years?
不客气。对，你说得对。对，我毕业只是因为这对我的父母很重要，但我已经受够了。我已经准备好前进了。对，我懂。等等，当时的目标是什么？嘿，你上过四年学吗？
Did you go to college? Yeah, I went to Illinois State University. Okay. And I have a scholarship fund set up there. Was that still Saluki's? Is that Carbondale? That's Normal Illinois. That's Normal Illinois. Yeah.
你上过大学吗？对，我上了伊利诺伊州立大学（Illinois State University）。好吧。我在那里设立了一个奖学金基金。那是叫萨卢基人（Saluki's）吗？那是卡本代尔（Carbondale）吗？那是伊利诺伊州诺摩尔（Normal Illinois）。那是诺摩尔，伊利诺伊州。对。
Isn't that a funny name? That's the name of the town. I have to say this though, I want to just say this. Because one of the best performances I've ever seen in my life was you in Good Night Oscar. That's very nice. Did you saw that? How great can I tell you how fucking blown away I was. That's very sweet. And this is just me being a kid of the age I am.
这不是个搞笑的名字吗？镇子名字就叫这。不过我得说这个，我只想说这个。因为我一生中看过的最精彩的表演之一，就是你在《晚安，奥斯卡》（Good Night Oscar）里的演出。太客气了。你看了吗？我能告诉你我有多他妈震撼吗？太甜了。这就是我这个年纪的人的真实感受。
The fact that that's not on film makes me want to murder somebody. That was such an incredible performance. That's very sweet Vince, coming from you that means a lot. Anyone that Tony deserved it. Anyone that fucking Tony deserved it. I think he should have gotten, if they could have given out two Tonys, I couldn't believe it. Two Tonys. If you did any one of those things, I was like, oh, he's older, he's got the fucking addictions.
那部戏竟然没有拍成电影，这事实让我真想谋杀某个人。那真是太不可思议的表演了。文斯，你这话太暖心了，对你来说意义重大。任何一个托尼奖都当之无愧。任何一个他妈的托尼奖都当之无愧。我觉得他本该得到，如果他们能颁发两个托尼奖的话，我简直不敢相信。两个托尼奖。如果你做了其中任何一件事，我都会想，哦，他年纪大了，他有那些该死的毒瘾。
And then the piano playing. It was flawless. At one point in my life, it was very sweet. I didn't have two Tonys. But listen, I... Did they take a Tony away? Did you get Reggie Bush? Did someone take a Tony away? Were you taking money on the side? No, no, one of the Tonys had to go home because his wife called.
然后是弹钢琴。简直无可挑剔。我生命中的某个时刻，这太甜了。我没有两个托尼奖。但听着，我……他们收回过一个托尼奖吗？你拿到雷吉·布什（Reggie Bush）的奖了？有人收回过托尼奖吗？你在私底下搞钱吗？不，不，其中一个托尼奖不得不回家，因为他老婆打电话来了。
So, is that what it is? Wait, but Vince, that's very sweet of you to say, and it means a lot coming from you. No, it's true. Did you guys both see that play? Oh, yeah. Are you kidding? We wept.
哦，是这样吗？等等，但文斯，你这么说太暖心了，对你来说意义重大。不，是真的。你们俩都看那部话剧了吗？哦，对。开什么玩笑？我们哭了。
We fucking wept. Jason sat in front of him. We wept. We turned and we were like, this is unbelievable. I turned to Will and I said, I think Sean's ruined the podcast now, because now we can't disrespect him.
我们他妈的哭了。杰森就坐在他前面。我们哭了。我们转过身，心想：这太不可思议了。我转向威尔说，我觉得肖恩现在把播客给毁了，因为现在我们不能不尊重他了。
Yeah. I said, I kept saying, I had no idea he had this in him. I had no idea. You could never tell. From any of his past work, you had no idea. No idea. No idea.
对。我当时说，我一直在说，我不知道他还有这本事。我真不知道。你根本看不出来。从他过去的任何作品里，你都绝对看不出来。完全看不出来。完全看不出来。
So out of left field. Very sweet. So we were just on a previous episode talking about audition stories. And one of the funniest thing, who was it that was like, was it Jason, it was you that would, no, was it you? That would walk through?
简直出乎意料。太暖心了。所以我们在上一集里刚好在聊试镜的故事。最搞笑的一件事之一，是谁来着，是杰森吗，是你吗，会……
Jason would say that when he'd leave auditions, Jason, what was you that would, no, was it you? That would walk through? No, Jason would say that when he'd leave auditions, Jason, what would you say to them? Oh, but it probably came across as an asshole, but I was trying to be sort of humble and not be as presumptuous that they would ever hire me and I would just, I would say, hey, good luck with this. As I left. Which is just such a wrong thing to say, but I'm trying.
杰森说他离开试镜现场时，杰森，是你吗，会……不，杰森说他离开试镜现场时，杰森，你会对他们说什么？哦，但这可能听起来像个混蛋，但我当时是想表现得谦虚一点，不要太自作多情地觉得他们会雇佣我，我会说，嘿，祝你们好运。当我离开的时候。这真是一句极其错误的话，但我当时在努力尝试。
You could take it the other way, where it's like, this is a fucking nightmare and no one's solving this problem. You know what I think they took issue with was the wink that you gave them with that. Yeah. When you gave them a full wink and then a wink. Like a babysitter leaving a house, sleeping with a kid. Good luck with that one. But I read that you did something really, wouldn't you go out and shake everybody's hand afterwards or something? Oh, I was fucking, yeah. Well, I didn a kid. Good luck with that one. But I read, you did something really, wouldn't you go out and shake everybody's hand
你可以从另一个角度来看，这就像是，这简直是个他妈的噩梦，根本没人能解决这个问题。你知道我觉得他们对什么有意见吗？是你当时对他们抛了个媚眼。对。当你向他们抛了个十足的媚眼，然后又抛了一个媚眼。就像保姆离开雇主家时，和孩子睡了一觉。祝你好运。但我读到过你做过一件很特别的事，你不是会出去跟所有人的手握手什么的吗？哦，我他妈的，对。好吧，我当时不知道，所以我以为这就像中西部的求职面试。
afterwards or something? Oh, I was fuckin', yeah, well I didn't know, so I thought it was like a job interview in the Midwest. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I would be overly kind of nice, and I think it was draining for the people. They just wanted to see you read, and could you do the part,
对，对，对。所以我会有过分友好的举动，我觉得这对其他人来说是一种精神消耗。他们只想看你试读，看你能不能演这个角色，
but I would go out of my way to be like, well it was a pleasure to meet you. They'd be like, who the fuck is this guy? Yeah. Well that's a nice thing? And then I would always say, I was kind of coming from an insecure place, not humble, but I would always, for some reason, compliment the screenplay or the script. I'd say, this is really great.
但我会特意跑去说，嗯，很高兴认识你们。他们会想：这他妈是谁啊？对。但这难道不是件好事吗？然后我总是会说，我当时是出于一种不安全感，而不是谦虚，但我总是出于某种原因，称赞剧本或台词。我会说，这真的很棒。
I mean, even if it was fucking terrible, I'd just say, well, this is great stuff. After you had just finished improvising, probably, right? I don't even know. But I didn't really improvise on those. I was more kind of stuck to the page. And yeah, it's a weird process. The audition process is weird.
我是说，哪怕它烂透了，我也会说，嗯，这东西太棒了。这很可能是你在即兴表演刚结束之后说的，对吧？我甚至不知道。但我并没有真正在那些试镜里即兴发挥。我更倾向于死守剧本。对啊，这是一个奇怪的过程。试镜这个过程真的很诡异。
Do you remember your last one? Well, the one thing in Swingers is because Favreau made fun of me, I had done a couple after school specials. By the way, I was gonna ask you about that. I saw you in one. Yeah, I did a couple of those. That was my bread and butter. Yeah, wow. I made my bones. I cut my teeth after school
你还记得你的最后一次试镜吗？嗯，《求爱俗辣》里的一个情况是，因为费儒取笑我，我之前演过几个课后特辑。顺便问一句，我正想问你这个呢。我在其中一个里面看到过你。对，我演过几个那种。那曾是我的衣食父母。对，哇。我靠那个打下了江山。我在课后特辑里磨练了演技……
We were tackling shit like sex and steroids and yes, I saw that I was bringing some sunshine to these houses that were filled in darkness Do you remember anything? Do you remember any of the dialogue from any of those that you've never been able to share? Do you or any scene that you've been like fuck? Yeah, one of them was a scene with Billingsley where I discover he's on steroids and I say you're wired all the time You're like some doper He wants him he wanted Nicole Egert I believe to like her and so he was He was pumping up some steroids to do some long-distance running
我们当时在探讨像性啊、类固醇啊之类破事，没错，我看到我给那些充满黑暗的家庭带来了一丝阳光。你还记得什么吗？你还记得那些你从来没法跟人分享的台词吗？你或者任何一个让你觉得“操”的场景？对，其中一个是和比利斯利（Billingsley）的对手戏，我发现他在用类固醇，然后我说你整天像打了鸡血一样，像个瘾君子。他想要尼科尔·埃格特（Nicole Egert）喜欢他，所以他用类固醇来增强耐力，好进行长跑。
And you know how they you know how they proved he was on steroids was, because he wasn't necessarily buff at the time, although in excellent shape. But he would just roll up the sleeves on his shirt one time. Once that was a transformation to say the steroids have happened. But I went in for an audition and I started and I didn't get and I was emotional. It was a real story. I came back and Fabro asked me about it and I said uh god I really had a great audition these people were moved I really got to the moment and I was like but I didn't get it because I'm like tall and I'm like three years older than they wanted for the party he's like well why are you even
你知道他们是怎么证明他在用类固醇的吗？因为他当时虽然身材极佳，但还没到肌肉暴起的程度。但他在戏里把衬衫袖子往上卷了一次。仅仅这个转变就足以说明类固醇起作用了。但我当时去参加试镜，我开始了，但我没选上，我当时很情绪化。这是一个真实的故事。我回来后费儒问起这事，我说，哦天哪，我当时的试镜真的太棒了，那些人都被感动了，我真的进入了状态，然后我说，但我没选上是因为我个子太高了，而且比他们要求的角色年龄大了三岁。他说，那你去试什么镜？我说，我不知道，是他们让我去的。所以他才用那个故事来取笑我，被我搞得好像我表现得惊为天人、演技精湛，只是因为年纪太大才没拿到角色，还在拖车里……
going in for it I said I don't know they just me in. So that's why he kind of was making fun of me with that story where I make it like I was phenomenal and really a great performance, but I was just too old to get the part and the trailer. No, I've worked with Peter once when I was a kid. He was on Little House on the Prairie. He played a little kid who stuttered named Gideon that I befriended. I think we're both like 11 or 12.
不，我小时候和彼得（Peter）合作过一次。他演过《草原小屋》（Little House on the Prairie）。他演一个口吃的小男孩，名叫吉甸（Gideon），我和他成了朋友。我想我们当时大概都是11岁或12岁。
For Tracy, Peter is the star of A Christmas Story. Yeah, yeah, and the director of Couples Retreat. Yep. Yes, and he just did a sequel that he produced and wrote for Christmas Story last year that turned out really well that was on HBO. Oh yes, yes, yes, yes, that was great. Vince, when are we gonna go back to Bora Bora
对于特雷シー来说，彼得就是《圣诞故事》（A Christmas Story）的主演。对，对，还有《伴侣度假村》（Couples Retreat）的导演。没错。是的，他去年为《圣诞故事》制作并编剧了一部续集，效果非常好，在HBO播出了。哦，对，对，对，对，那部太棒了。文斯，我们什么时候能回波拉波拉岛（Bora Bora），
and do Couples Retreat too? Was that a fun location? Oh God, it was the greatest call I ever got. I think you and Stuber called me and said, hey, we got a part for you in this film. We've named the character Jason. We wrote it for you. Right, we're gonna shoot on Bora Bora
拍《伴侣度假村2》？那是个好玩的地方吗？哦天哪，那是我接过的最棒的电话。我想你和斯图伯（Stuber）打电话给我说，嘿，我们在电影里给你留了个角色。我们给这个角色起名叫杰森。我们是为你量身定写的。没错，我们要去波拉波拉岛拍一个半月。
for what, a month and a half. It was the biggest payday I've ever had. It was like the greatest job ever. You were great, you were great, always so funny and it was like our Burt Reynolds phase. What do you mean? Well we just go to a location that's great instead of story. It's a bunch of friends. Cannonball Run, it's like I don't know, it looks like those guys were like let's go. But we just were looking for a place that would be you know know, amazing that no one had heard of and that's what they found.
那是我赚过最多片酬的一次。简直就像最棒的工作。你太棒了，你一直都那么搞笑，那就像是我们的伯特·雷诺斯（Burt Reynolds）时期。什么意思？就是我们只去风景绝佳的地方拍戏，而不管剧本如何。就是一群朋友聚在一起。《炮弹飞车》（Cannonball Run），就像是，我不知道，看起来那些家伙当时就像是在说“我们走吧”。但我们只是在找一个大家都没听说过、却美得惊艳的地方，而他们就找到了那种地方。
That's the best. We should do the sequel on a ski mountain. You guys did a couple movies together, right? You did that, you mentioned Starski. Yep. What else? Break Up. Break Up.
那真是太棒了。我们应该去滑雪山上拍续集。你们一起拍过好几部电影，对吧？你拍过那个，你提到了《警界双雄》。没错。还有什么？《分手男女》（The Break Up）。《分手男女》。
I feel like there's another one. I'll think of it. Jason's funny, makes me laugh so hard. Some of the stuff you added just in that scene with Jen and I on the couch, when you're like the counselor in the realtor was so funny. You guys, I would work so hard
我觉得还有一部。我想得起来。杰森太搞笑了，把我逗得前仰后合的。你在那场我和珍（Jen）坐在沙发上的戏里加的一些台词，当你扮演咨询师和房地产经纪人时，简直太搞笑了。你们俩，我当时工作得极其努力，
because you just go through a rehearsal with Vince and you just see how facile he is and then when they bring in second team to write it, I would run to my trailer and I'd break out a little piece of paper and a pencil and I'd come up with all my alts, all my little things that I'm gonna add and sort of, oh yeah, which is like the biggest mistake,
因为你只要跟文斯排练一遍，你就能看出他有多敏捷，然后当他们把替补演员（second team）带进来走位时，我就会飞奔回我的拖车，掏出一小张纸和一支铅笔，想出我所有的备选台词，所有我打算加入的小把戏，哦对，但这简直是最大的错误，
you know, like you get it all prepared and all loaded and then you go on to set and so now you're trying to shoehorn in some stuff that when I'm practicing my faces in my trailer, it all works great. But then of course, you know, Vince is just like in the moment like you should be and adding great shit and then I'm putting in these lines
你知道的，就像你把一切都准备就绪、弹药上膛，然后你走到片场，于是你现在开始强行塞进一些你在拖车里对着镜子练习表情时效果绝佳的玩意儿。但当然了，你知道的，文斯就像你该做的那样，完全沉浸在当下，随性加入极棒的梗，而我却在硬塞那些跟当时的情境毫无关系的台词。
that have nothing to do with what about this. Yeah, and so many times I get these looks from Vince like, hey motherfucker, what are you doing? Like you're wrecking it. Just shut up and set me up and move on. Oh Jesus. Oh God, that was a great lesson. I remember you always coming up with fun stuff.
对，所以很多时候我会收到文斯投来的这种眼神：“嘿，他妈的混蛋，你在干什么？你把戏给搅砸了。闭嘴，给我做球，然后演下去。”哦，天哪。哦天哪，那真是一个深刻的教训。我记得你总是能想出各种好玩的东西。
Not nearly enough. And adding stuff. I don't recall it that way. I don't know how you do it. We wouldn't be able to do it with a straight face. I mean, it must be important. Vince, do you remember one time we went to some charity thing we sat next to and the whole time Vince was in my ear commenting on everything that was happening.
远远不够。而且还不断加戏。我不记得是这样的了。我不知道你是怎么做到的。我们要是一脸严肃地演根本演不下去。我是说，这一定很重要。文斯，你还记得有一次我们去参加某个慈善活动，我们坐在旁边，整个过程中文斯都在我耳边对发生的一切评头论足吗？
And I was like, I'm going to have to leave this fucking place because they think I'm laughing at everybody. Oh yeah. That's your face man? And then the guy gets up who's hosting and he goes, this is your face man? This is the guy you guys decide? And I start fucking crying. Ted Sarandos said he's the guy of honor.
当时我就想：我得他妈的离开这个地方了，因为他们以为我在嘲笑所有人。哦，对。这就是你的脸吗？然后走上台主持的那家伙说：这就是你的脸吗？这就是你们选出来的家伙？然后我他妈的哭了起来。特德·萨兰多斯（Ted Sarandos）说他是荣誉嘉宾。
He's looking at me from across the table like, why are you ruining my moment? I'm like, this guy's fucking- Maybe that's why I was invited back. You're fucking killing me. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You know, I think, were we just talking, were we just talking to Kimmel or somebody about, or was it Fallon when you guest hosted,
他隔着桌子看着我，眼神仿佛在说：“你为什么要把我的高光时刻给毁了？”我说，这家伙他妈的……也许这就是为什么我又被邀请了。你他妈快把我笑死了。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。你知道，我想，我们刚刚是不是在跟吉梅尔（Kimmel）或者什么人聊过，还是说你当客串主持的那次是法伦（Fallon），
was either Kimmel or Fallon and- Letterman. Was it Letterman? Some of them were talking to one, and it was without a doubt like the best week of hosting of any talk show of any year. Vince, would you ever consider that, but just I would just like to see you
是吉梅尔还是法伦，然后——是大卫·莱特曼（Letterman）。是莱特曼吗？有人跟其中一个聊过，毫无疑问，那是任何脱口秀在任何一年里最棒的一周主持。文斯，你会不会考虑那个，但我只是想看到你
on a nightly basis freestyling. Me too. It's enough already with the acting and go on the location. You got a family, Vince. Let's get you a nice studio job where we can enjoy you on a nightly basis. Yeah, we only get to see you cracking jokes a couple times a year.
每晚都在即兴发挥。我也是。别再演戏了，赶紧去外景地吧。你有家庭了，文斯。让我们给你找一份安稳的演播室工作，这样我们就能每晚欣赏你的表演了。对啊，我们一年到头只能看到你好几次开玩笑。
Like, it'd be like fucking nightly out there just fucking roasting people. Come on, man. You know, it was fun to do the one time, but I think I'd get bored night after night. Wouldn't you guys? Like, this is fun. You guys, this is a super fun show. And you guys have fun. You have each other to joke with.
那感觉就像他妈的每晚都在外面狠狠地疯狂吐槽别人。拜托，老兄。你知道的，做一次挺好玩的，但我觉得日复一日地做我会觉得腻。你们不觉得吗？就像，这挺好玩的。你们这档节目超级好玩。而且你们玩得很开心。你们有彼此可以开玩笑。
You get fresh meat every night, Vince. And you can just sit there and just cherry pick and throw bombs. It was Letterman, right Vince? It was like it was it was letter. I had fun doing it It was fun, but but I don't I don't think I would I think I would just get bored Don't you like going on to a new project? Yeah, but you know you take a bunch of months off and you can go do your thing, you know Yeah, do you think you find people do you find Jesus Christ know? Do you, Vince, do you find people, do you find? Jesus Christ, man, are you dying?
你们每晚都有新鲜的素材，文斯。你就可以坐在那里挑挑拣拣，然后扔出重磅炸弹。那是莱特曼，对吧文斯？那感觉就像是莱特曼。我当时玩得很开心，这很有趣，但我不认为我……我觉得我会感到无聊。你不喜欢去接手一个新项目吗？对，但你知道的，你可以休息好几个月，然后去搞你自己的事情，你知道的……对，你觉得你能找到人，你觉得……耶稣基督，你知道吗？文斯，你觉得你能找到人，你觉得……耶稣基督，老兄，你快不行了吗？
I miss him, Will. Do you find people, Vince, like with quote funny people, do you expect people, do you find that people expect it from you right off the bat? Is it something you have to turn on and it's exhausting, but once you turn it on, you're good to go, but you like to turn it off and just chill out and stay silent, like what do you like at on, you're good to go, but you like to turn it off and just chill out and stay silent.
我太想念他了，威尔。文斯，你有没有发现，人们，比如所谓“搞笑的人”，你会不会觉得人们从一开始就对你抱有这种期待？这是不是某种你必须开启的东西，而且这很耗费精力，但一旦开启了，你就状态极佳，不过你其实更想把它关掉，安安静静地待着，就像你在……状态极佳，但你其实更想把它关掉，安安静静地待着。
Like, what do you like at home? Do you like to spar with your wife? I think the three of us might be similar where I don't like to be on all the time. Yeah. You know, I don't. I like to joke around and I appreciate a sense of humor, but I'm not out there swinging all day.
比如，你在家里是什么样的人？你喜欢跟你的老婆斗嘴吗？我觉得我们三个可能挺像的，我其实不喜欢一直处于营业状态。对。你知道的，我不喜欢。我喜欢开玩笑，我也欣赏幽默感，但我可不会一整天都在那儿挥棒。
I like to kind of slow it down. Like, I like to joke, but I don't like that. But when I first moved here. Sorry, go ahead, Sean, when you first moved here. When I first moved here. Is this close to your dream? Mm-hmm. So you're driving out from normal.
我喜欢把节奏放慢一点。比如，我喜欢开玩笑，但我不喜欢那样。不过当我刚搬到这里来的时候……抱歉，你接着说，肖恩，当你刚搬到这里来的时候。当我刚搬到这里来的时候。这接近你的梦想吗？嗯哼。所以你是从诺摩尔开车过来的？
Yeah. No, when I first moved here, I was really, really young, and I think I was just always on because I thought I had to be. Right. And now that I'm older, I'm like, boy, God, did I exhaust a lot of people, I'm sure. What are you gonna come on?
对。不，当我刚搬到这里来的时候，我真的非常非常年轻，我觉得我当时总是处于营业状态，因为我以为我必须那样做。没错。而现在我老了，我在想：天哪，我当年肯定把很多人都折腾累了，我敢肯定。你什么时候才打算营业？
When are you gonna turn on, do you think? When will be the moment? When we're rolling, Sean. You know, Vince, I bet you get the same thing. I was thinking, like, Farrell kinda gets it too, which is when people see him, they're like, oh, this is the fun, funny guy. For Farrell, it's like, oh, you're Hank the Tank.
你觉得你什么时候会开启这个状态？当我们实拍的时候，肖恩。你知道的，文斯，我敢打赌你也有同感。我在想，就像法瑞尔（Farrell）大概也有这种感觉，那就是当人们看到他时，他们会觉得：哦，这就是那个搞笑的开心果。对法瑞尔来说，人们会觉得：哦，你是“坦克汉克”（Hank the Tank）。
You're the party guy who's crazy. So I'm going to come at you because you're crazy. And I bet you I wonder if you get that A and B people feel, you know, sometimes you meet people and they they decide they're going to play with you, but they kind of play too hard. They get weird and they say something kind of critical or shitty. And you're like, that's not the game, man. Yeah. But but they try to they try to come at you, so they come at you hard.
你是那个疯狂的派对达人。所以我得来找你，因为你很疯狂。我敢打赌，我在想你是否也会遇到这种A面和B面的人，有时你遇到一些人，他们决定要跟你过招，但他们下手有点太重了。他们变得很诡异，说一些带有批判性或尖酸刻薄的话。而你会想：这根本不是在玩游戏，老兄。对。但他们试图针对你，所以他们下手很重。
You know what I mean? Yeah, I think younger, more so, once in a while, someone thought they were funny for their group. So they would try to do something. And I would really eviscerate them. I would get their friends to fucking turn on them. And I would have a private moment. Their friends would be laughing at them. And I would have a private moment like looking at them like you thought this was
你知道我的意思吗？对，我觉得年轻时更是如此。偶尔会有人觉得自己在自己的小圈子里很搞笑。所以他们会试图搞点什么事情。而我会把他们批得个体无完肤。我会让他们的朋友都他妈的倒戈。然后我会有一个私密的时刻，看着他们的朋友在嘲笑他们，而我会用一种眼神看着他们：你以为这事
going to go good, like this is your story. You wanted this, here we are. But then I kind of figured it was better, I think as it was better as I got older, you just kind of, you know, try to kill them with kindness, right? You learn that minimal is better. But as I get older, I still get a lot of quotes and yes, people will come up. But now that the comedy's played,
会进展得很顺利吗？这可是你自己的剧本。你自找的，现在我们在这儿了。但后来我发现这样更好，随着年龄增长，我发现最好还是……你知道的，试着用善良去感化他们，对吧？你懂得了“少即是多”。但随着我年龄的增长，我仍然收到很多引言，是的，人们会走过来。但现在喜剧已经演完了，
you guys tell me, because isn't it funny, as you get older, people will share with you how they were hurting or a family member was sick and how the comedies was really something they would watch multiple times. So now it's more of an emotional connection than it was when it first hit younger when it was just kind of a funny connection. All the time. All the time. We get this, especially
你们告诉我，难道不觉得很有趣吗？随着年龄的增长，人们会跟你分享他们当年是如何经历痛苦，或者某个家庭成员生病时，你的喜剧是如何成为他们反复观看的慰藉的。所以现在这变成了一种情感上的连接，而不是刚出道年轻时那种纯粹搞笑的连接。一直都是。一直都是。我们经常遇到这种情况，尤其是
this because it's such a weird format because people hear us and so they can do shit and whatever. And we started our thing in 2020 and these guys will attest to it. You get a lot of people come up and go, I had a really tough year. I lost my dad and I was at home alone and I couldn't talk to anybody, and you guys, blah, blah, blah. And it's kind of meaningful too. Like it feels, you're like, oh great, like I'm happy about it.
因为这是一个很奇怪的节目形式，人们能听到我们的声音，所以他们可以做各种事，等等。我们在2020年开始了我们的节目，这两个家伙可以作证。你会遇到很多人走过来对你说：我度过了非常艰难的一年。我失去了父亲，我独自在家，我没法跟任何人说话，而你们，啦啦啦啦。这其实挺有意义的。就像，你会觉得，哦太好了，我对此感到高兴。
That was me, I told you I lost my dad, yeah. Yeah. Well you didn't lose him. We found him, he just went town over. Yep. He's at a motel. Bender. Big bender.
那个人就是我，我跟你说过我失去父亲了，对吧。对。嗯，你没失去他。我们找到他了，他只是去了隔壁镇。没错。他在汽车旅馆里。狂欢。狂欢大派对。
Big bender. 30 year bender. 30 year bender. Yeah,ender. 30 year bender. 30 year bender. Yeah, Vince, your dramatic work lately is like stunning. My dad just sent me an email the other day saying just how knocked out he was on something he just saw with you doing, that you didn't. Are you loving doing more of that as you get older
狂欢大派对。30年的狂欢。30年的狂欢。没错，狂欢。30年的狂欢。30年的狂欢。对，文斯，你最近的剧情片表演简直惊艳绝伦。我父亲前几天刚给我发了一封邮件，说他看到你演的某部戏时被惊艳到了，而那甚至不是……随着你年龄渐长，开始思考更成熟的事情，你是不是越来越喜欢这种表演了？
and you're thinking about more mature things or whatever? I don't know, I certainly am, but I do miss doing comedies. I miss doing, I miss the studio comedy, you know, that you've done a ton of, I've done a few of, I'd love to do more. Do you miss that a bit? Do you have any knowledge or forecast as to any of that stuff coming back?
我不知道，我当然很喜欢，但我确实很怀念拍喜剧。我怀念拍喜剧，我怀念片厂喜剧，你知道的，你拍过一大堆，我也拍过一些，我很想多拍点。你有点怀念吗？你对这些东西会不会回归有什么了解或预测吗？
Do you have any idea why there's so few of them being made nowadays? Yeah, first off, I think the same as you. My journey's been the same as you. I was fortunate to do like Hacksaw Ridge and then this stuff with Zoller, Brawl and Drag. But now I'm dying to do a comedy again. Like I'm so, it's like Sullivan's Travels, right?
你知道为什么现在拍这种东西的人越来越少吗？对，首先，我想得跟你一样。我的心路历程跟你一样。我很幸运能拍《血战钢锯岭》（Hacksaw Ridge），然后是佐勒（Zoller）的那些作品，《切尔西大酒店》（Brawl in Cell Block 99）之类的。但现在我渴望再次拍喜剧。我太想了，这就像是《苏利文的游历》（Sullivan's Travels），对吧？
Like, you know, and like Ozarks, I thought, and it was incredible in the fact that you were, you know, directing those and running those on top of it. And you get your plate full, I'm sure, it's great and it's fun, but it does make you miss in agreeance with you, that kind of... Nice studio ensemble comedy where you're working every other day, maybe.
就像，你知道的，还有像《黑钱胜地》（Ozark），我觉得它不可思议的地方在于，你居然还要在一边导演和运作这些。你肯定忙得不可开交，这很棒也很有趣，但这也确实让你怀念，我也同意你的看法，那种……那种美好的片厂群戏喜剧，也许你可以每隔一天去工作一次。
Yeah, yeah, just showing up every time. Yeah, it's true. And then I think as far as it going away, you know, here's what I'll say to you. I just was saying this. I think what happened is we went through a terrible time. Like, if you remember the 80s, they tried it with the lyric censorship of those albums. Like when NWA, I thought, was such a great album,
and then they started putting these warning labels on albums, like parents. And it kind of made the albums blow up. Like, the albums still came out, and it made everyone buy them more. But I think they succeeded a little bit with the studio system to say, now we're going to decide what's funny,
what's not, or what's joking, which is crazy. Cause it's my opinion. Like if you go back to Greek mythology, human nature has always been the same. And, you know, clearly with entertainment, it's, it's a place to explore a song, a story is a place to explore rage or lust or selfishness or anything. It's the outlet.
It's like MMA is the place to explore or football, you know, conflict, not out on the streets, but most people, you know, watching a football game don't take that as a sign that they will get rewarded for tackling someone. So I think there's just a lostness of like how dumb people must be to think like this is a how-to video. It was insane to me. And so I think we went through this reign of terror of being policed of what is and what isn't
versus leaving people their tone. But it never went away, and I mean that, Jason, from this. I think you guys can appreciate this. The stand-up comics when we were doing the big R comics were not that huge, meaning there was a real run in the 80s. They all got their own TV shows. And, you know, people, you'd go on Carson and that was it. You were off to the races.
That was the path. That was the path. But then, like in the 90s, I did this documentary for some guys that I liked that were comics because there just wasn't opportunities. Well, then what happened was the appetite from the audience for funny, odd, adult, dangerous, shocking comedy never went away.
But because the studios weren't making them, you know, Bill Burr, who's great, and other comics like him started selling out Madison Square Garden. They started selling out the Forum. And Netflix started paying $20 million for those specials instead of putting that money behind a story and a movie. So it never really went away. and started song out the forum, and Netflix started paying $20 million for those specials instead of putting that money behind a story and a movie.
So it never really went away. Those guys were always making jokes in areas, like Bill will make fun of having to stand up for veterans, which isn't an obvious path to the waterfall, or men and women relationships. But people laugh and he gets to do it in a way where society appreciates it and no one takes it as a literal thing. So I think like it never went away,
it really helped the standups, but my sense is that it's gonna come back roaring in a big way. Yeah, me too. Because, and I think anything other than that of any kind of questioning of it is just an illustration of like how arrogant someone might be to think they're in charge of like who the fuck is worthwhile.
But what's interesting about that is that all these, it used to be such a great point, that the stand-ups, you'd make it to a certain level, you'd do whatever, you'd do Carson, you'd get a huge deal, and not all of them were great actors or could act in film. Now they don't have to, because they can just do a special a year for $20 million, and getting a movie or a show
is not the ultimate objective for them anymore. They don't need it. Although, if we look back at the great comics, a movie, when it's done well, is always more memorable than the greatest stand-up special. As good as Delirious is. 100%. Right, we all go to 48 hours.
Yeah. Right. Because it's a story that when it works, it's such a powerful thing. So yeah, I think it's, and now some of them are going, like if you look at even what happened with Shane, with Gillis, you know, there was like, he can't, now they're all clamoring for Shane
because he built an audience, you know, was able to reach people directly, you know, and people realize this guy's funny and coming with a point of view and he's trying to make people laugh, right? So he's really had a huge opportunity because he was able to go directly to the audience. That's a model that, you know, I think.
Was this that model in some ways, do you think, this podcast? No, this felt, this was an accident. It was, sorry JB, not to, I think it was, bear with me, with the idea that we started it with nobody, we paid for it for the first year. I mean, we had advertisers, but it took us a little while just because producing the episodes and the equipment
and all that kind of shit. So it was just us, right? I mean, in had advertisers, but it took us a little while just because producing the episodes and the equipment and all that kind of shit. So it was just us, right? I mean, in that way it was. But we never assumed anyone was gonna listen to it and that it wouldn't be around after COVID. We thought it was gonna be three, four months, something like that. Yeah, we really.
Here we are and we get to talk to our favorite people and it takes an hour a week and we just could not feel more- I can't believe it's taking us as long to have Vince on. Can You? I'm taking this as he's talking. It's like unbelievable. How the fuck was he not our first guest?
This is unbelievable. By the way, he is our first guest on our new deal on SiriusXM. Are you serious? No shit! Yes. Let's cut the ribbon. This makes sense that we have Vince as our first guest
on fucking SiriusXM. This is, I was gonna say, we were gonna add it later, but I think that's safe to say. And thank you, Fence, by the way, for wanting and willing to be our first guest. It's a big honor. What a great start.
We just need you to wear a ball cap for six weeks, if you don't mind. It's just as serious, it's just when you're going to the market, whatever, you're picking up the kids, don't fucking sweat it. You can leave it in the car. No, I'll have it as an option, you know. Some days on, some days off, and we'll be there with it.
All right, listen, wait, speaking of all, I love that philosophy, you were talking about all the comedy stuff, and I totally agree. It's interesting. Do you think, like, who was it for you growing up? Who were you like, gosh, if I could do that, or I could be like that, or I could have that career, I could follow his kind of trajectory?
Red Fox. Yeah, I loved Red Fox, it was all of those guys. You know, there was stuff I used to just watch, like, endlessly. And I would just, I always kind of gravitated to the, I think it's a little bit like, well, isn't it like with kids, you hide your eyes and then they laugh because you're getting ahead of them.
It's like horror. The jump scare and the joke, there's something in going where you don't expect it. Yeah, it's all surprise. Yeah, surprise, right? So the stuff that was more, you know, kind of like points of view that was not, Norm was such a fun place in a show or a movie
to see someone with that attitude was fun. That's why Bateman in It's Your Move made me laugh. It kind of reminded me like J. Foxx had that. Right, right, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he did. But you gotta stay ahead to surprise people and that's what you're, I think, uniquely better than anybody I've ever worked with as far as just staying ahead
and really coming up behind somebody. It's an incredible gift and I love you for it. It's incredible. It's really good. I have a couple things I wanna go through when you were kids growing up in Chicago. Yeah, this is the time to do it. Oh, so just some admin? Just some admin or?
No, yeah, I gotta check these out. We had to tee him up so he knows that you're gonna ask him something. Yeah, here comes a question, Vince. Okay, go ahead. No, wait, so did you know we were born in the same year and we were in Chicago? I'm kidding. Yes, we were. So wait, Buffalo Grove, did you ever we were born in the same year and we were in Chicago? I'm kidding.
This again? Yes we were. So wait, Buffalo Grove, did you ever go to Woodfield Mall, Oakbrook Mall, or Yorktown Mall? I went to Woodfield Mall, Brookfield Mall, and then I went to Northbrook Court. Yeah, because I worked at those malls. And then I used to go to a small one in Vernon Hills,
Hawthorne, Hawthorne was a good one too. Oh yeah, I know, I don't know. All right, so I'm trying to find, okay, so, and then, wait, first of all. Great America was a place that took your dollars. I went all the time. Great America, which is now Six Flags, which is now something else.
Which is now Six Flags. The Demon? The Demon, oh my God, I rode the Demon all the time. Okay, here's a trivia question for you. You put the gum, with the gum on the top? When you went through, people would stick their gum on the top when you walked. They were proving they were there, but it was fast. Yeah, that was fast. Question for you, what was the name on the top? When you went through, there was, people would stick their gum on the top when you walked through. They were proving they were there, but it was fast.
Yeah, that was fast. Question for you, what was the name of the roller coaster before they turned it into the Demon? The Eagle? No, the Eagle was later. That was the fastest wooden roller coaster. And as you would wait for two hours in the Midwest, the thing we would share with each other is say,
this is the biggest wooden roller coaster in the world. That was ours. What was it before the demon? It was, what? I believe it was turn. Oh, yes, I don't remember. What is it? Turn of the century.
Turn of the century. Wow, how do you, how do you make that? I can confirm or deny it, but I believe, it's tough to ask such a trivial question you don't know the answer to, but I'm pretty sure that that's what it was. I can't ride rollercoasters anymore. I'm too old, my equilibrium gets shot,
and I'm immediately nauseous. I can't do it. I'm the same way. I went to Disneyland with the kids, and I was like, I did one ride, and I was like, I'll see you guys later. One ride. Yeah, what happened?
He left. You show up super excited, you're gonna get the kids everything. I'll get all hopped up on sugar. You guys are on your own. I'm gonna be texting over here on a bench. I was texting on the bench, and then I kept going, and then I kept going,
and then I kept going, I kept going like they'd come back and I kept going, you guys wanna take off? Let's get out of here, right? You guys wanna go to the small world or you wanna go home? Those are your options. So we bring the world together? Or we getting out of here?
Oh my God, that's so true. Do you get back to Chicago a lot? I know that you go to Blackhawks games, I've seen you there. Yes. and and but do you do you spend a lot? Do you still feel really tied to Chicago? I do you know, I always say I grew up in Chicago I was I was raised in Chicago, but I grew up in California because I moved here at 18 So I always felt a connection I think everyone from there does and then I always felt such a connection to California because at 18 I moved here and made it my home.
But I do go back in the summer. I always enjoy going there. It's a super fun city. Lots of fun, obviously. I set the break up there because I was from there and I wanted to be in the city. So yeah, in the summertime I'll go back usually. But with the kids, I'm so busy with kid stuff.
Aren't you guys running around like crazy? Yeah, but it's so hot in the summer there. I remember it was boiling when we did that movie there. Why would you go there in the summer? You got a deal there or something? The winter's cold, the winter's a different, the winter's a tougher after cold. In 2010 you skydived over Chicago
as part of the Air and Water Show. And I remember seeing that and I was like, why is he doing that? Yeah, what happened? And to be in full disclosure, the night before I ran into some of the Blackhawks and I had a couple of drinks that evening. Come on.
I was up late. What? I was. And so I got up with a very few hours of sleep. No. But I was committed, I made a date with Skydiving and I didn't break the date. And you just kind of- Wait, you fucking Skydove hungover?
Yes. Yeah. I wouldn't do it. I didn't know what was happening, you just kind of... Wait, you fucking skydived hungover? Yes. I wouldn't do it. I didn't know what was happening. I was just honking to the golden knights. They were very professional. They were military. They were great. And they were telling me all the things. Had you done it before?
I brought my mom. My mom was with me. No, I have never... That was the first time you skydived and you didn't hangover. Yes, and I enjoyed it. It was an interesting thrill, but it's not something I would sign up for all the time. But it was enjoyable. Are you guys... Have you skydived, the three of you?
No, I was about to. I think maybe with the same group. And then I realized a week before, what's the feeling I'm going to have when I hit the ground? It's going to be that I made it. And I don't want to do stuff that I'm excited that I made it. You know, I have children now. I think the three of you to go skydiving would be a nice time. You three should book a date on the calendar, circle it. Right, and we shouldn't do separately, we should just be bound as one.
Take it easy, Sean. Oh, you think? Yeah, we should just make a train, huh? Come on, guys. Yeah, I think I would do it. I think I would do it. Really? You've got four kids.
I know, but you know what? You be safe, you're attached to the people, you do an air train. How does that make it safe? You just both die. I'll do it, I don't have kids, so it's okay if I die, is that what you be safe. You're attached to the people you do an air train How does that make it safe? So I'll both die. I'll do it. I don't have kids. That's okay if I die Yeah, sure you do it. You got that dog. What's that dog's name? Yeah, yeah Scottie oh Ricky sweet Rockies got it Scotty and Rocky What Ricky Ricky? There you go And now a word from our sponsor And now back a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show.
But now, Vince, you know that I, this is true, I just saw Rudy for the very first time, maybe a year or two ago. Really? Never saw it. And I didn't know, it's one of Scotty's favorite movies. Oh, quick review. Yeah, it was incredible. It was incredible.
And when I saw you, I was like, oh my God, so this is part of the beginning of your whole thing. And then I saw a favorite, I was like, oh, I didn't know John was in, like, I didn't know anything about it. And how soon after that did you and John decide to hook up in Right Swingers? Was it like right after?
Well, he moved out from Chicago after Rudy, and then we became friends on the set, and so we hung out and we moved to Hollywood. And I used to go to all those places, were real places. I used to love to go hear the swing music. All the ex-punk rockers formed these swing bands, and then the Dresden was just a great local bar with all ages.
I loved the Dresden, because you could get like a 75-year-old in there. And it was just like, I liked Marty and Elaine were so fun to go watch. Yes, Marty and Elaine were great. Yeah. So I love that. And then John moved to that area. And so we used to just hang out and go out a lot. And then I think I said to him one day, like kind of what Jason was saying just now, which was, why are we auditioning for these scripts and these things that are so out of touch
and like, what's going on? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because a lot of the scripts were either like tough guy scripts, where like everyone knew everything or they were like, you know, they just weren't fulfilling of the time and so John, I said maybe write something and John came back and had wrote Swingers and I think in like two weeks or three weeks,
he got like a screenwriting book and kind of put it in that form and then we started meeting and talking and going through the script and talk about you know all this stuff but the part that was crazy was that we thought we could get it made you know when you look back at it that's the part that's insane. We were like under our wing we're like okay well we're gonna make this so now let's start the journey. We'd meet like a couple times a week, talk on the phone a lot, okay, who do we think we can get? It was crazy. Yeah, yeah, yeah, but that's how you get shit done.
You believe in it. But you guys can see, because all three of us were born in the same year, I didn't wanna say, because I didn't wanna blow your mind. Now that is a coincidence. No, I was 16. That's a cool year, that 1970. That's in that 1970 no that's in my notes. That's in my nose unbelievable and
And I remember I was living in New York I was a young actor living in New York and when that movie came out for us It was as Gen X rose. I was I was like this is a fucking movie that fucking gets it It's telling the kinds of jokes and the way that I want it to be done It was surprising as JB was saying with the language that was hilarious and unusual and fucking references that were phenomenal. Yes and also made me feel like like being an actor in that moment you were just speaking to me and everybody else. Speaking to me and it wasn't jokes written in a studio system
they didn't feel like it was rewritten by a bunch of different known comedy teams this was new it was different and it was rewritten by a bunch of different known comedy teams. This was new, it was different, and it was real. They were jokes that you could see these guys were real guys. It was like you guys were like rookies of the year and MVP in the same year. It was just like bang. You know what I mean? What was that feeling like? What was the moment on Swingers?
What screening was it or what was the thing where you were like, holy was the moment on Swinger? What screening was it, or what was the thing where you were like, holy fuck, this is really reaching people? The thing that was interesting was that you could imagine the crew we assembled was not, they were just people looking for a job. I think our sound guy specialized in adult films. Sure.
And so we're really committed in taking it. I always wondered about that. Because the sound seemed very erotic. I think the set was a slow day for him every day. But we were taking it serious. And I think the scene, there's the scene where I stand up on the table was improvised, where I stand up
and I start doing the dance and stuff at the restaurant. And the reason I did that was, partially I could just feel like the crew looking at us, like what are these guys, like the whole shoot, like what's going on? And so I kind of made it like, I'm the asshole, I'm the asshole at the restaurant, kind of came from like, I was kind of reacting
to the crew's feeling of like, this guy's out there and people are looking at you in a restaurant like you're going too far, but it was really kind of that. to the cruise feeling of like this guy's out there and people are looking at you in a restaurant like you're going too far. But it was really kind of that. So we loved it, but it wasn't like, you know, on the set, other than the actors, there was a real feeling that this thing was working. And then we did not get into Sundance was the first step. And then but we still loved the movie. And then it got picked up, obviously, by Miramax and released. And then it but we still loved the movie, and then it got picked up obviously by Miramax and released, and then it really just kind of grew over time.
It started to get quoted so much, and ESPN started saying, your money, baby, and then Vegas Baby started being sold as kind of you. So then it just sort of hit this, and I think part of what I think worked about it is there was a vulnerability to these guys. They weren't winning every situation. They're not, everything's not going their guys. They weren't winning every situation. Yes.
They're not, everything's not going their way. They don't have all the tools. And it was really a friendship in that you're helping someone pass a breakup. And I think the vulnerability, and you go out going to meet girls, but a lot of times you'd end up playing EA hockey. Yeah, totally.
And ordering Pink Dye. So I think there was a relatability that wasn't taking itself too seriously. You know what's funny, now that you mention it, there was a sort of a tragic element to it, right? It's kind of a tragedy in a way. It's kind of sad. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Right? You know what I mean? Like it made the comedy much more profound. It's like an American with Nail and I in that way, that film of just like at the end, you're like, they don't really win. They don't, you know, like it's kind of. Well, you pass in time.
The one thing with the last scene of the movie was, I was flying home to do the movie, to do Swingers. And I was sitting at the airport, waiting, you know, in these rows of seats and I could see the counter. And there was an older gentleman at the counter who kept smiling and waving at me. And I had not done anything, no one knew who I was.
So I was like, why is this guy so confidently like waving at me like real aggressively? So I tried everything. I tried to be like, not, I was distracted. I tried to look at him mean. I tried to, you know, roll my eyes at him, but it did not deter him. He was just overly playful and doing shit with me. I try to look at him mean, I try to roll my eyes at him, but it did not deter him, he was just overly playful and doing shit with me, I was like, what is going on?
And then once he got his ticket, he came walking right towards me, and I thought, this can't be real, no one can be this fucking tunnel vision, this is crazy. And he walked right in front of me, and he had a baby that he was entertaining in the row in front of me. And I was like like this is fucking crazy
I thought this motherfucker was waving and smiling at me I really he's entertaining a fucking toddler So I called John and I said, you know, cuz Trent is is such a great character and confident and fun and all of it but you really focus on the transformation of His character of growing and sort of the great thing that John wrote in the movie is when he kind of is himself and doesn't try hard at the bar and says, yeah, I like quiche, real men. He's like, yeah, I guess my reputation.
When he's not trying to be something he's not is when the door opens, is when the girl connects to him. And so the kind of compliment to that at the end, I thought it was fun if you go, because some of those movies would always wrap up where the character would explain the movie at the end, I thought it was fun if you go, because some of those movies would always wrap up where the character would explain the movie at the end. You know, here's the monologue where I tell you the theme of the movie. And I'm like, why are they doing that?
If the movie did its job, I don't need the character to explain the theme of the movie to me. So kind of as a misdirect, the fun of it was for Favreau to say, you know what, I didn't know, and then all of a sudden it hit me, and you're like, oh God, they're gonna do this in the movie where now the character explains the journey. And then I start thinking the girl is waving at me and smiling at me as a way to sort of pay no attention to the man behind the curtain. Like, you know, Trent is, in the way he sees things,
a good friend and helpful, but John kind of gets quiet and stares off as if to say he's not searching for some pickup stuff, you know, or how to meet someone. He sort of found an inner truth that's kind of transcended him into this next phase of his life. And so I think there's, there's an optimism because you know, he's got past the breakup and there's the openness for love. And we're also kind of moving past, which I think is an important stage, that adolescent stage that we all go through, where you are figuring out how do you make a connection,
how do you say hi to someone, how do you date. There's a moving past that to being more yourself and finding a partner that likes you because you're comfortable with who you are. Yeah, for sure. And fuck, by the way, I love that. Makes me wanna, I'm gonna watch it again tonight. Makes me wanna see it. Oh, Sean. No, don sure. And, and. Fuck man, that's great. By the way, I love that. It makes me wanna, I'm gonna watch it again tonight. Makes me wanna see it. Yeah, me too.
Oh, Sean. No, don't? No, do. I was just gonna, I was about to drop on, Vince, I can't tell you how many times I've said to people earnestly I've ripped, but I just, I go, you, and they were like, fuck, he's about to, I go, you are so money,
you don't even know how money you are. I've said it a million times. Wait, so you, you married married a Canadian just like your mother, but you didn't marry your mother. You married Kyla. Well, we all do. Well, we all do in our own ways, don't we? Oh, shit, Jesus, fuck, let me.
Don't think I haven't woken up with fried chicken on my mind, my brother. Mm. We all go through that cycle, don't we? Uh-huh. So, go through it every day. And I put my house on the market years and years and years ago and decided not to sell, but I heard that you saw it, you checked it out.
Do you remember that? Oh, did I? Yeah. I probably, I might have. Where, without giving away too much, are you? Hancock Park, Hancock Park. Okay, although we gave away a lot, but yes. Yeah.
I love that, I lived in Hancock Park. I lived on Rossmore when I was real. Oh, really? Yeah, I live not too far from there. I love that area. Yeah, that's pretty cool. What's the address, Sean? Wait, I didn't grow up skateboarding, I don't have balance in that way. I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I'm not a surfer, I didn't grow up skateboarding, I don't have balance in that way. I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I'm not a surfer, I didn't grow up skateboarding, I don't have balance in that way.
I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I respect the ocean,'m not a surfer. I didn't grow up skateboarding. I don't have balance in that way. I respect the ocean. It's a powerful entity. I like to go in and cool off. Good for you, man. I like to go in and cool off on occasion.
My kids like to go. It's like the amusement park. That's the thing with waiting to have kids until you're older. I'm conscious, like, I don't want to be, you don't want to be an old father. So you force yourself to do the stuff right one would have done when they were younger but sometimes I'm not filled with joy why I'm participating right listen listen Vince I had another kid I had my youngest son I had him when I was 50 but
the good thing is I wear vans so people there they don't know how old I am because they're like this guy's wearing vans he can't be over 30 yeah he must be at least, you know. But I also like the way that you said you respect the ocean is if it's this thing that you're saying it because if you don't say that, it's gonna come get you. So you lay your respects on it. But what about it?
Vince, what about it? What about it scares you? Because what scares about me is like, I've never, I guess all the movies I've seen, did you see Open Water? Do you remember that movie, Open Water? Jostle was a tattoo on my brain. Billy Zane, Open Water?
No? I don't know if Billy, I don't remember who's in it. There's the couple that goes, they go scuba diving and they come up and the whole team is left in the middle of the ocean. Don't you remember that? I'm like, I can't do any of it. I didn't see that.
Now I have a new one to watch. Oh yeah, it's so scary. So what are you doing over there at Manhattan Beach? You like in a volleyball league or anything like that? You know, my daughter plays volleyball. Her team just, she plays for a volleyball club, Mizuno at 13, and they took third in the Junior Olympics. Is that right? No shit.
Yeah, good for her. That's amazing. So she got your height and your leaps? She's a good athlete. Yeah, she's on the tall side. She enjoys that. But yeah, we're just here, you know,, the kids and stuff, they get a lot of freedom to walk around and kind of participate and do stuff.
是的，真替她高兴。太棒了。所以她遗传了你的身高和弹跳力？她是个好运动员。对，她个子挺高。她很喜欢这样。不过对，我们就在这儿，你知道的，孩子们什么的，他们有很大的自由可以到处走走，参与其中做点事情。
I like the freedom for the kids. I think it's so nice if they can kind of navigate their own friend day, like the way we did, if the parents aren't so involved. It's easier for us, and I think they get to grow quicker what they like and what they don't like because they're making those choices and this gives a little more freedom to bike around and be able to do that.
我挺喜欢给孩子们这种自由的。我觉得如果他们能像我们当年那样，在父母不过多干涉的情况下，自己安排和朋友相处的一天，那真是太好了。对我们来说更容易，而且我认为他们能更快地明白自己喜欢什么、不喜欢什么，因为是他们在做这些决定，这让他们有了更多骑车出行和做这些事情的自由。
But you know what, that's so important, and Vince, I've been thinking about this a lot, all bits aside, we talk about this a lot with like the phones and stuff, right, with the kids. I have a 13-year-old son and a 15-year-old son and the phones are crazy. And I said to them, we've talked a lot about it here, Jason, Sean and I have, and I said to my kids,
但你知道吗，这太重要了，文斯，我一直在想这件事，抛开别的不谈，我们经常讨论手机之类的事情，对吧，关于孩子们。我有一个13岁的儿子和一个15岁的儿子，手机简直太疯狂了。我对他们说——我和杰森、肖恩在这里讨论过很多次——我对我的孩子们说，
look, I'll give you more, there'll be a, if you spend less time on your phone, I'll give you more personal freedom to do shit and go out and hang out with your friends. And I'll back, because I think us as parents, we got so into this thing of like, we got so worried about our kids going and doing shit and yet we'll give them a phone and let them go to the far reaches of the
听着，我会给你们更多……如果你们少花点时间玩手机，我会给你们更多的个人自由去做想做的事，出去和朋友闲逛。我会支持你们的，因为我觉得我们作为父母，太陷入这种状态了——我们太担心孩子们出去胡闹了，然而我们却给他们一部手机，让他们去探索互联网的无边无际。
internet. And it should be the reverse, right? I agree. I so agree with you. If you look at us, all of us born in 1970 and even in our conversation with two of us, some of us not going to college, we were given a lot of bandwidth and we made mistakes, but there was a lot of figuring out just problem solving. Yes.
本末倒置了对吧？我同意。我太同意你的看法了。如果你看看我们，我们所有人都是1970年出生的，甚至在我们两个人的对话中，我们有些人没上大学，我们当时有很大的自主空间，我们犯过错误，但也有很多摸索和解决问题的时候。是的。
And so I think if you're too restrictive with the kids, you know, if you do it Little House style, like you and Peter B, then they just, they have a harder time. Like when do they actualize? Is it at like 17, all of a sudden you say, okay, now you're going out there. So I think having conversations,
所以我觉得如果你对孩子管得太严，你知道的，如果你搞“草原小屋”那一套，像你和彼得·B那样，那他们就会……他们的日子会更难过。比如他们什么时候才能真正成熟？是在17岁左右，突然有一天你说，好吧，现在你可以出门了。所以我觉得多沟通，
hopefully they feel comfortable talking to you about stuff. But you're right, if you go to a mall, or you're on the phone, you have a chance to come across stuff that the parents aren't involved in. And it's better for them to figure out that navigating to some degree, with guardrails, obviously. Yeah, right. Yeah, you don't want your kids moving a ton of weight up through South Florida, you know
希望他们觉得跟你谈论事情时很自在。但你说得对，如果你去商场，或者玩手机，你就有机会接触到父母并不知情的事情。他们自己去摸索这些程度，当然要在有安全底线的前提下，对他们更好。是的，没错。对，你肯定不想让你的孩子在南佛罗里达运送大量毒品，你知道我的意思吗？
what I mean? I mean, this is... Even if he promises that we're all going to wet our beaks on it, I'm like, listen, you're not doing it. You know what I mean? Listen, Vince Vaughn, before we let you go, I want to talk about Bad Munch. But first of all, we didn't even get to like Jurassic Park, Psycho, Made, Old School, Dodgeball, Wedding Crash, Breakout, True Detective, Curb.
我是说，这……即使他保证我们所有人都能从中分一杯羹，我也会说，听着，你不能这么做。你知道我的意思吗？听着，文斯·沃恩，在我们让你离开之前，我想聊聊《劣质猴子》。首先，我们甚至还没聊到《侏罗纪公园》、《惊魂记》、《同义词》、《老校园》、《疯狂躲避球》、《婚礼傲客》、《制胜一击》、《真探》、《抑制热情》。
Oh, Dodgeball, that's another one. Curb. That, you are so funny in that, Bate. Ah, I just read that, it was just an anniversary of that. There was some long article on The Ringer that Ross had sent me that's just awesome to revisit. Yeah, fucking, when you read that out. You stole that fucking, you were so fucking funny
哦，《疯狂躲避球》，那是另一部。还有《抑制热情》。那个，你在里面太搞笑了，贝特。啊，我刚看到那个新闻，正好是那部剧的周年纪念日。罗斯发给我一篇《The Ring》杂志的长文，再次回顾真的太棒了。对，他妈的，当你读到那段的时候。你偷了那个他妈的……你在那部电影里他妈的太搞笑了。
in that movie. That is the commentator. But tell us about Bad Monkey Vince before we let you go. It's with Bill Lawrence, and for Tracy, Bill Lawrence created Scrubs, he created Ted Lasso. Spin City. Ted Lasso. No, he's great.
那个解说员。不过在让你走之前，文斯，给我们讲讲《劣质猴子》吧。这是和比尔·劳伦斯合作的，特蕾西，比尔·劳伦斯创作了《实习医生风云》，他还创作了《足球教练》。《旋转城市》。《足球教练》。不，他很棒。
I used to play in a poker game with him when I was like 19, and he was super funny. And he was a comic at the time. So I knew him, he was a friend and then. Is Bad Monkey a comedy or is it drama? Well it's kind of both. It's a Carl Hiaasen book about a detective in Florida and so the personalities are fun and comedic
我大概19岁时经常跟他一起玩扑克牌，他超级搞笑。他当时是个喜剧演员。所以我认识他，他是个朋友，然后……《劣质猴子》是喜剧还是剧情片？嗯，有点两者兼有。这是卡尔·海亚森的一本小说，讲的是佛罗里达州的一个侦探，所以里面的性格都很有趣、很搞笑，
but the stakes are real and the kind of crime you take seriously. And so it was just great to get a chance to work with someone who's such a good writer, who, as an actor, you can go and play around, be funny, watch your ideas. Yeah. And, you know, but knows, you know, he knows how to put it together,
但事情利害攸关，案件也是你需要认真对待的那种。所以能有机会和这样一位优秀的作家合作真的很棒，作为一个演员，你可以去尽情发挥、搞笑，还能采纳你的想法。对。而且，你知道，但他懂，你知道，他知道怎么把这一切串联起来，
and you're not gonna, you know, have to go through that process. So that, Bill's, you know, I think for all of us, when you work on a set and you've done it as long as we have, and this is another thing, as we get older, when we were younger, the crews were so dialed in. You had to be an apprentice to be a prop person for years, right? And so now they're making so much more stuff.
你不会，你知道，不得不去经历那种折磨人的过程。所以，比尔的……我想对我们所有人来说，当你在一个剧组工作，而且干了这么久像我们一样，还有一件事，随着我们年龄增长，我们年轻时，剧组的专业度极高。你得当好几年的道具学徒，对吧？所以现在他们制作的东西太多了。
So when you get to go on a set and it's really well run and the guy in charge really is fun and it makes it for a good day. Yeah, that's great. Amen. I can't wait to see it. The bad monkey. Yeah, that's great. Amen. I can't wait to see it. The Bad Monkey is where? Is on what?
因此，当你能进到一个运行得非常好、负责人也真的很有趣的剧组时，这会让这一天变得很美好。对，太棒了。阿门。我等不及要看了。《劣质猴子》。对，太棒了。阿门。我等不及要看了。《劣质猴子》在哪里？在什么平台上？
That's on Apple. On Apple. On Apple. Gotcha. That's great, and it's August 14th. Can you imagine saying 25 years ago, you're watching, it's on Apple. What?
在苹果平台上。在苹果。在苹果。明白了。太棒了，8月14日上线。你能想象25年前有人对你说，你正在看，这个在苹果上播出的。什么？
I know. Yeah, I know, right? What are you talking about, man? What, your show's on Apple? Get the fuck out of here. We don't serve junk. Put some fucking shoes on, you know? Uh, Vince, we've taken up a lot of your Saturdays,
我知道。对啊，我知道，对吧？你在说什么呢，老兄？什么？你的节目在苹果播出？滚开。我们这里不招待垃圾。穿上你他妈的鞋子，你知道吗？呃，文斯，我们占用了你很多周六的时间，
so we appreciate it. Absolutely love you so much. Such a fan of the show and all of you guys. It was a blast to get the chance to come on and talk to you guys. So great to see you all. So great to be with you again, Vince. Vince, you're an all-time champ, man. Honestly, you are an all-time fucking champ. You're the funniest fucking dude.
所以我们非常感激。绝对是爱死你了。我是这个节目和你们所有人的超级粉丝。能有机会上节目和你们聊聊简直太棒了。很高兴见到你们所有人。很高兴再次和你在一起，文斯。文斯，你是个永远的冠军，老兄。说真的，你绝对是个他妈的永远的冠军。你他妈的太搞笑了。
And thanks for being on our maiden voyage to Syria. Yes. Big deal to us, so thank you. This looks like blue skies and clear waters ahead, so thank you for having me as a passenger. Oh, he referenced the ocean again. Say hi to the family, Vince, please. I will.
谢谢你成为我们首航西里西亚（注：应为SiriusXM卫星广播）的嘉宾。是的。这对我们意义重大，所以谢谢你。看起来前方是一片蓝天和清澈的海水，所以谢谢你让我当乘客。哦，他又提到了海洋。代我向家人问好，文斯，拜托了。我会的。
Please me as well, Jace. Great to see you guys. Bye, buddy. Thank you, buddy. Bye. The great Vince Vaughn, Double V's. No kidding. Double V's makes a W.
也请代我问好，杰斯。很高兴见到你们。再见，老兄。谢谢你，老兄。再见。伟大的文斯·沃恩，双V。开玩笑吧。两个V连起来就是一个W。
He's so, and such a sweet man. So sweet. So easy. Just so, his comedy is so easy, like seeming easy, what I mean, you know what I mean? Like there's just like an, it's so fluid. But if you guys, you guys haven't worked with them before, have you? No, I wish.
他真是个大好人，太温柔了。太温和了。太自然了。就是那种，他的喜剧感太自然了，看起来毫不费力，我是说，你懂我的意思吗？就像是有一种，太流畅了。不过你们，你们以前没跟他合作过，对吧？没有，我真希望能。
Okay, I'm telling, when you work with that guy, like when they bring in the slate, they say, okay, Rollin', they come in, they hit the slate, ready, and action, and you look at this guy and you know, like it's a Tommy gun coming at you. You know, you usually take sort of comfort and peace knowing that, okay, we're all dealing with
好吧，我告诉你，当你和那家伙合作时，当他们拿场记板进来，说“好，开机”，他们走进来，打板，准备，然后“action”，你看着这家伙，你知道的，就像有一把汤姆逊冲枪朝你扫射一样。你知道，你通常会感到安慰和平静，因为你知道，好吧，我们都在剧本的基础上
a mutually agreed upon plan here with the script. I know what the next line's gonna be, I know what the next action's gonna be. With him, it's always up in the air in the greatest way, and you just gotta keep your knees bent the whole time. And you wanna enjoy it as an audience member, so you're kinda like half laughing the whole time, but then you can't,
达成了一个共同认可的计划。我知道下一句台词是什么，我知道下一个动作是什么。而对和他合作来说，一切都充满变数，而且是以最棒的方式，你整个人必须时刻保持高度警惕。你作为观众会很享受，所以你基本上全程都在半笑状态，但你又不能笑出声，
because you gotta stay in character. It's just exhausting in the best, best way. Oh, constantly. Like Tambor level, Jeffrey Tambor level, where you just can't look him square in the eye, otherwise you're gonna laugh. You gotta kinda stare at a cheek, or a nostril or something.
因为你得保持角色状态。这简直是以最棒、最棒的方式累死人。哦，简直是持续不断。就像坦博尔级别的，杰弗里·坦博尔级别，你根本不敢直视他的眼睛，否则你就会笑出来。你必须盯着他的脸颊、鼻孔或者什么地方。
But I did ask him about that question. I asked him about like, you know, cause I've been asked to do like improv. About the malls? Yeah, call him back. Was that the one about the mall he likes? Which malls he likes to go to? No, cause I worked in those malls.
不过我确实问过他那个问题。我问他关于……你知道的，因为我也被邀请去演那种即兴表演。关于商场的事？对，叫他回电话。是那个关于他喜欢哪个商场的问题吗？他喜欢去哪个商场？不，因为我在那些商场工作过。
What the fuck's the matter with you? I worked there. This guy is so. So, but I asked about that improv thing because you know, you have to flip, you have to switch on like when you're asked to improvise and it's like sometimes when you're not in the mood, how do you do it?
你他妈的有毛病吧？我在那儿工作过。这家伙真是……所以，但我问了关于即兴表演的事，因为你知道的，当有人要求你即兴发挥时，你必须立刻切换状态，有时候当你没那个心情时，你是怎么做到的？
Like how do you get there? It's just the older I get, I'm like I can't do it. I need somebody. Yeah, but don't you find like, I find like with this, like when one of us is tired or when, I'll speak for myself, when I'm tired, I'm just like, well, I'll just embrace it, I'll just use it, well now I'm just gonna be
比如你是怎么进入状态的？随着年龄越来越大，我发现我做不到了。我需要有人……对，但你不觉得吗，我发现，像这样，当累了的时候，或者当……我替我自己说，当我累了的时候，我就会想，好吧，我接受它，我顺其自然，好吧，现在我要变得比平时更烂。
even shittier than I usually am. You know, just like, you know, and you just become drier and that becomes your humor for the day. That's very good, I do that too. I do that too, Jason. I think that happens a lot, yeah, I think that we've gotten older, as we've gotten older, certainly that's kind of the thing.
你知道的，就像那样，你会变得更冷酷，那就会成为你当天的幽默风格。这非常好，我也这么做。我也这么做，杰森。我觉得这种情况经常发生，是的，我觉得随着我们变老，随着年龄增长，这绝对成了一种常态。
You look great. It's easy to do it here. Will, you look great. No, but just about the, you just show up with what you got today. Yeah, yeah, for sure. And it is what it is. Yeah. And it's not defined, it is deal with it,
你看上去状态很好。在这里做这个很容易。威尔，你看起来状态很好。不，但就是关于……你今天有什么状态就拿出来什么状态。对，对，肯定的。事情就是这样。对。这不是被定义为“去接受它”，
but it's not like, hey, fuck you, it's just like, hey man, this is where I'm at right now. I don't have, I can't give what I don't have today. Yeah, and you know what, Jay, and I was worried because I know that you've been really tired, you've been burning it, you've been working your tail off, and then you know what? Here it comes, here it comes.
而是像“嘿，操，这只是说，嘿老兄，这就是我目前的状态。我没有，我今天实在给不出更多了。”对，你知道吗，杰伊，我当时很担心，因为我知道你一直真的很累，你一直在拼命赶进度，你一直在拼命工作，然后你知道吗？来了，来了。
You were fucking so perfectly fine. Oh yeah. Yeah. I thought we were gonna get a bio to you. No, no, I knew you, no, I'm just kidding, I knew you were tired, but you know, it's just one of those things. And like, you find a way, and then you see Vince,
你他妈的表现得太完美了。哦，是吗？对。我还以为我们要给你叫救护车呢。不，不，我知道你……不，我开玩笑的，我知道你很累，但你知道，这就是那种情况。你会找到办法的，然后你看到文斯，
watching your face light up when you saw Vince. Yeah, I know. It was so fun. I was almost gonna text you, Jay, that it was Vince, and I was like, I love him. It was so fun. I forgot how many times you guys have worked together. By the way, that reminds me of one of the funniest things
看到你看到文斯时脸上放光的样子。对，我知道。太有趣了。我差点要发短信告诉你，杰伊，那是文斯，当时我想说，我太爱他了。太有趣了。我忘了你们合作过多少次了。顺便说一句，这让我想起了文斯做过的最搞笑的事情之一。
Vince ever did. We were doing the junket for Couples Retreat, and he and I were paired together. And the only way we got through the junket for couples retreat and he and I were paired together. And the only way we got through the junket was this game that he played where each time the journalist would come in, he would, we'd take turns giving each other a word that you had to work into your answer. And so like, you know, Constantinople would be like, you know, or, you know, or Velcro or something,
我们当时在为《伴侣度假村》做宣传采访，我和他被分到了一组。我们能熬过《伴侣度假村》采访的唯一方法就是玩一个他发明的游戏：每当记者进来时，我们就轮流给对方一个词，你必须把这个词硬塞进你的回答里。所以，比如说，“君士坦丁堡”，或者，你知道的，或者“尼龙搭扣（Velcro）”之类的，
and she would just fucking kill me. Because he's just so straight, so dry. That's funny. And then when you did, did you guys just crack up? Yeah, exactly, and then of course, the poor journalist thinks that we're having a laugh at his or her expense, and they don't know what it is, and it's just dumb actor crap.
而他总是能把我逗死。因为他表情太一本正经、太冷面滑稽了。太搞笑了。然后你们做完之后，你们俩是不是就笑喷了？对，没错，然后当然了，那个可怜的记者还以为我们在拿他/她开玩笑呢，他们一头雾水，不知道是怎么回事，这纯粹是演员的无聊把戏。
Anyway, I'm so glad he came on. It was a long time coming. I was excited for you guys to see what's happening. Nice guest. I mean, really good. Again, it is surprising that we haven't had him on earlier because he's such a fucking heavyweight. I'm fucking serious.
总之，我很高兴他能来。这一天等了很久了。我很兴奋能让你们看看正在发生的事情。很好的嘉宾。我是说，真的很棒。话说回来，我们这么晚才请他来确实挺让人意外的，因为他是个他妈的重量级人物。我他妈是认真的。
I want a daily dose of him. Wouldn't he be an incredible talk show host? Amazing. Amazing. Amazing. He's made for it. He is. Do you guys get acid reflux ever? Oh, here it comes.
我真想每天都看到他。他难道不会是一个 increíble（极好）的脱口秀主持人吗？太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。他简直就是为此而生的。他确实是。你们有没有过胃酸倒流的时候？哦，来了。
Oh my God. You know what it is? Strap that in. I can't. It's a twinkle in his eye or something. No, I'm just asking if you ever get acid reflux. Yeah, sure, sometimes. No, you know what, Sean?
哦天哪。你知道这是什么吗？系好安全带。我受不了了。他眼里闪烁着某种光芒还是怎么的。不，我只是问你们有没有过胃酸倒流。对，当然，有时候会有。不，你知道吗，肖恩？
No, we don't. Let's just move on to another subject. No, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna yes and him, because I just can't wait for this turd. Well, I'm just gonna say, sometimes I get acid reflux, so I have to. Is that right?
不，我们没有。让我们换个话题吧。不，我要……我要顺着他的话说下去，因为我太期待这个蠢货的表演了。好吧，我只想说，有时候我会有胃酸倒流，所以我必须……是这样吗？
Yeah, so sometimes I drink water, you know, to balance the acid-base pH, you know, kind of thing. Sure. And one of those things I drink is bicarbonate, and I was wondering if you guys. I just want to buy it again. I was wondering if you guys have ever had bieeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee
对，所以有时候我喝水，你知道的，来平衡酸碱度pH值，你知道，诸如此类。当然。我喝的东西之一就是碳酸氢钠，我想知道你们……我只是想再买一次。我想知道你们有没有喝过……
and I would like to say a nice normal on our very first episode on Sirius to our incredible listening audience thank you for being with us. Thank you for staying with us. Thank you. And have a great day and a very pleasant and sincere. Thank you for stopping. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
我想对我们在Sirius的第一期节目的忠实听众说一声美好而正常的感谢，谢谢你们陪伴我们。谢谢你们留下来。谢谢。祝你们有美好的一天，并致以真诚的谢意。谢谢你们的收看。再见。再见。再见。再见。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Finally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。最后由Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbicoe和Michael Granteri手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。